john stumpf the chairman CEO wells fargo
in the news right now from what you
understand of what happened it wells do
you think it's appropriate for him to
keep his job as the head of that company
you know let's have a little personal
responsibility here and what troubles me
about Wells Fargo right now is either he
didn't know in which case there was a
massive long-term fraud on his watch
does that mean this is just another bank
that is too big to manage remember this
is one of the banks that could threaten
our economy this is one of the banks
that just failed its living will test
meaning could it be wound down without
taking out the rest of the the American
economy either that is the case or it's
the case that he actually did know what
was going on that he did have an idea
that there were criminal activities
within the bank either way he needs to
be held accountable for this as does the
rest of his senior management and just
to clarify there that means step down as
you see it hey what you should not be
able to keep your job and keep raking in
the millions of dollars in bonuses and
in particular look also at this woman
who ran Kerry told state entire yes who
ran the whole of consumer division the
idea that she could be in charge of this
division get yearly bonuses based on how
much fraud was occurring in her division
right they called it cross selling but
in this case we now know fraudulently
opening you know a million and a half
checking accounts more than half a
million credit cards that she was
getting bonuses all along and now she
walks away with a hundred and twenty
five million dollar bonus
for having presided over a division that
systematically broke the law and cheated
customers this tells me that something
is badly broken at that bank it tells me
that notwithstanding everything that we
talked about following the crash of 2008
that the culture at this giant bank is
still about profits even if it means
cheating people and breaking the law
that's bad for their customers that's
bad for the rest of the economy
investors have called for clawbacks
analysts have called for clawbacks we
haven't heard anything from Wells Fargo
itself about those in this case do you
think it's appropriate here that we
should see some clawbacks absolutely